und alle fragen sich wieso und wieso
gerade jetzt nun ganz einfach prägossen
Kanne rechnen er weiß das Putin des
Jahresende das Geld ausgeht denn ja es
geht wieder mal nur um Kohle wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass Russland eine Mafia
startet allerdings ohne Ganoven Ehre
putin hatte sein Regime auf der Realität
seiner Unterstützer untereinander
aufgebaut aber dieses klettokratisches
System stößt jetzt an seine harten
Grenzen weil einfach nicht mehr genug
Leute da ist um sie unter allen zu
verteilen aufgrund der westlichen
Sanktionen und der hohen Kriegskosten
wäre dazu teilende Kuchen immer kleiner
und hatten Herne switchen dann eben in
den Kannibalen Modus aufmerksame Politik
Zuschauer werden sich daran erinnern was
wir bereits im Frühjahr gesagt haben so
wie es damals schon aussah würde
Russland bis Ende 2023 ein Defizit von
über 100 Milliarden Dollar aufweisen bei
Reserven von 150 Milliarden unsere
Annahme wurde aufgrund der eskalierenden
Kriegskosten durch die Realität jedoch
weit übertroffen das zeigen die jüngste
Zahl
allein von Januar bis Mai ist das
russische Haushaltsdefizit auf 42
Milliarden Dollar explodiert womit sich
das Gesamtdefizit Beginn des Krieges auf
82 Milliarden Dollar erhöht hat das
bedeutet dass die Wirtschaft jetzt voll
und ganz aus ihren reservenschifft und
seit Februar mehr als die Hälfte übrig
gebliebenen 51 Milliarden Dollar
verbrannt hat im April waren die
Einnahmen aus Öl und gasexporten um 64%
eingebrochen so viel zum Thema das China
und Indien Europas Exportmarkt ersetzen
könnten Russland war sogar gezwungen
seinen Rohstoffexport zu subventionieren
um die Raffinerien und Ölquellen nicht
stilllegen zu müssen dieses Subvention
haben sich laut der vorliegenden Zahlen
aus dem April gegenüber den ersten
Quartal sogar verdoppelt wohlgemerkt das
alles sind offizielle russische und
daher geschonte Zahlen kurz gesagt Putin
geht schlicht und einfach die Kohle aus
mit der all seine korrupten Verbündeten
bei Laune halten könnte und wie gesagt
bring gossin kann rechnen und hatte sich
daher schon seit längerer Zeit gut auf
diese Situation vorbereitet wohl viel
besser als seine Rivalen das kann man
aus den Erfahrungen des letzten Jahres
und dem schnellen vorrückenwagen als
nach Roßdorf und Moskau schließen ebenso
aus dem überlaufen großer Teil der
rosgardia Polizei das ist FB und gro auf
Seiten pregartens das alles ist kein
Zufall Wagner wird sehr schwer
aufzuhalten sein bringt euch einen
kommentiert nicht nur über 25
000 extrem Kampf erprobte und bestens
koordiniertes sondern dürfte auch über
zahlreiche Schläferzellen verfügen das
heißt über Unterstützer innerhalb der
regulären Sicherheit und Streitkräfte
sowie 10.000 Veteranen die ihm die treu
geschworen haben natürlich geht es auch
dabei wieder um Kohle im Gegensatz zu
Putin verfügigen aber über einen Städten
Geldstrom aus seinen afrikanischen Minen
auch darüber haben wir schon berichtet
unter dieser Voraussetzungen kann aus
einer Meuterei natürlich schnell ein
Bürgerkrieg werden aber bisher ist er
das Maß an Gewaltlosigkeit beeindruckend
in dem alles über die Bühne geht das ist
natürlich auch darauf zurückzuführen
dass jeder in Russland weiß dass es
sinnloser Selbstmord wäre sich der
erfolgreichsten Kampfgruppe im Land
unkoordiniert in den Weg zu stellen die
Aufstellung einer Forst entsprechender
Stärke würde mindestens 48 bis 72
Stunden Vorbereitungszeit erfordern denn
es geht hier nicht nur darum eine
Handvoll Terroristen aufzuhalten der
Kreml muss das Kriegsrecht ausrufen und
viele weitere komplexe Schritte
unternehmen während in die Zeit davon
läuft und Prägungen entschlossen handelt
deswegen konnte Wagner Rostock auf einen
extrem wichtigen Knotenpunkt für die
Versorgung der russischen Truppen in der
Ukraine quasi kampflos besetzen und mit
den dortigen Vorräten an Munition
Treibstoff und Essen den vier Flughäfen
oder Schwarzmeerflotte in Rock kann
Wagner sein Vorhaben gut absichern zudem
kann Krieg auch schon auf diese Weise
die nun abgeschnittenen russischen
Truppen in der Ukraine als Reise nehmen
und als Postbank für eventuell
Verhandlungen nutzen gerade als wir
dieses Video veröffentlichen hat
Gregorian damit begonnen seine Truppen
von Marsch auf Moskau wieder
zurückzuziehen um Zitat kein russisches
Blut zu vergießen er könnte von Putin
also einen sehr guten Deal bekommen
haben wie gesagt es geht immer um Kohle
aber Putin könnte auch gewisse
Personalwechsel im
Verteidigungsministerium und in der
Armee durchführen umbrigogens
Vorstellungen von einer effektiven
Strategie zu genügen dies könnte für die
Ukraine eine sehr schlechte Nachricht
sein denn gerade die Unfähigkeit der
bisherigen Führung war als die ihr
bisher so in die Hände gespielt hat
allen die jetzt frohlocken das Ende des
Krieges erwartet haben könnten also
enttäuscht werden auf jeden Fall haben
wir es aber auch mit einem neuen
multipolaren Russland zu tun mit einem
indem nun klar ist dass die Macht nicht
mehr in den Händen eines starkes Mannes
liegt sondern zersplittert ist Putins
Image in in und Ausland wird nie wieder
so sein wie vorher die weitere
Entwicklung können wir nun in Echtzeit
über die Nachrichten und Social Media
beobachten hier auf visualpolitik sind
wir jedoch für die großen Zusammenhänge
und hochwertige Prognosen zuständig und
daher könnt ihr auch gleich drei Videos
zum Thema gespannt sein an den wir
gerade unter Hochdruck arbeiten darin
wird es um alle Hintergründe des Wagners
gehen darum wer Putin der Erben wird und
welche Auswirkungen dies auf die Ukraine
haben wird also unglücklich nicht
vergessen falls nicht schon geschehen
teilt dieses Video bitte auch mit euren
Freunden und sagt ihnen Bescheid damit
auch Sie wissen was wirklich abgeht
gerade in Zeiten wie diesen wird viel
verwirrender und klarer Blut sind
verbreitet und wer alle müssen den durch
qualitativ hochwertige aber vollständige
Informationen entgegenwirken ich danke
euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit wir sehen
uns sehr bald wieder
[Musik]